wsj ominöse was geht ab herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video hier
mal wieder auf einem kanal und so ja ich
war in letzter zeit ein bisschen kein
deswegen konnte ich jetzt nicht so
strukturiert überlegen was ich bin video
raushauen
ihr fragt mich aber eher wie machst du
deine haare wie können die so hoch gehen
oder so keine ahnung warum auf jeden
fall habe ich mir gedacht und macht doch
einfach mal dieses get ready with me
wird eine einmalige sache sein ich
wünsche euch viel spaß und ja es
wirklich mal so was hier im gesicht zur
veränderung
so leute mit wenig sagen wir von dirk
wann ich habe mir so ein paar sachen
schon rausgelegt oder die einzigen
sachen die ich brauche ich habe jetzt
keinen spiegel hier stehen das heißt ich
muss immer auf dieses neben display von
der kamera gucken deswegen wundert euch
nicht wenn ich so ein bisschen schief an
linsen objektiv vorbeigucken ja hier
sind die ganzen sachen wir legen wir los
und zwar fange ich logischerweise machen
damit ich meine zähne zu putzen
aber ich habe jetzt hier keine zahlen
müsst ihr wisst ihr schon alle meine
zahnbürste aussieht ich habe so eine
elektrische das ding mit so einem dreh
als dran
und ja deswegen fangen wir direkt mal
ich mach mir irgendwie als erstes immer
meine haare und zwar habe ich das bis
vor kurzem mit summen beauty kissmann
wachs gemacht habe ich aus österreich
den gibt's hier irgendwie nicht sonst
hätte ich denn hier wieder gekauft
er ist auf jeden fall richtig gut wenn
in österreich wo einkaufe gehen ja ich
will jetzt keine werbung macht hast du
bist nicht irgendwelche verträge mit so
judt kosmetik läden wie diese ganzen
blogger warum die da jeden tag
irgendwelche beauty food produkte
vorstellen auf jeden fall fangen wir
hier macht dann das ist dieser wachs
dieses wachs und hier ist nummer sei aus
wachs den benutze jetzt und zwar nehme
ich damit immer so eine sonne spitze das
ist es nicht besonders viel aber auch
nicht besonders wenig durch in meiner
hand und verleiht das ganze ziemlich
stark dass überall was ist sieht auch
immer so aus als hätte ich viel davon in
der hand weil der ist halt weiß wieder
wachsen hat es ja auch nicht jeder weiß
dass jeder weiß keine ahnung
und dann sind die hände so ziemlich weiß
machen wir das in die haare
so biss einfach ein scheiß egal wie
die sind ja schon sitzt ihr buch dann
auch noch an den seiten hier oben damit
man so den unterschied zwischen dem
undercut oder wie man das nennen und dem
den haaren auf dem kopf
ja und jetzt könnte ich sie
normalerweise schon ein bisschen stylen
sag ich mal
aber ich war mit dem handtuch durch habe
ich ja schon mal in einem anderen video
gezeigt und zwar sehen wir dann so aus
und jetzt kann ich die noch ein bisschen
besser verschieben
und ja dann nehme ich einfach hier so
eine bürste macht immer ein bisschen
höher und die seiten auch noch und zeigt
kann man schon die haare mal hier oben
ja als nächstes mache ich dann immer so
eine kleine mischung also damit mein
gesicht nicht so trocken aus wie bei
meinem gesicht trocknen mache immer so
eine kleine mischung aus um dann immer
nach der rasur eigentlich nur aber ich
find die gail deswegen nämlich sonst mal
keine ahnung habt ihr vielleicht schon
mal gesehen und bb weil meine wenn meine
haut immer so ist oder so dann vereint
das macht das ein bisschen in mein
gesicht
kreutzer
ja also so jetzt bin ich auch schon
eigentlich fast fertig mit
kaum zu glauben aber ich bin jung ich
glaub ich kommen viele jungs brauchen
jetzt so lange wie mädchen sich fertig
zu machen eigentlich kein junge manchmal
nehmen wir natürlich alle sonnencremes
beispiel wenn das wetter so ist wie
heute
weil ich mir extrem schweren sonnenbrand
wurde habe ich letztens auch da hatte
ich ab hier direkt vor sonnenbrand egal
und also wie gesagt bis dahin masters
jetzt und dann kommt natürlich noch so
ein bisschen so für luft und so habe ich
von meiner freundin hat mir das geschenk
dieses kay one
habt ihr bestimmt auch schon mal gesehen
kann man auch fast überall kaufen meine
haare schon bald wieder runter so das
mache ich dann einfach hier drei mal
drauf war das jetzt viermal keine ahnung
und dann riecht das bisschen besser
bis dahin also ich sehe jetzt ja schon
einigermaßen okay aus so wie ich immer
aussehen
jetzt sind meine haare so ein bisschen
ist der wachs eingezogen das match beim
einlegen wie immer die sind so ein
bisschen ja richtig dünn und dann fallen
schnell wieder runter aber jetzt kann
man diese immer ganz cool wieder hoch
machen und um die dann so ein bisschen
zu halten nämlich einfach hier diesen
styling sprayer ultra strong steht der
überall drauf aber die hälfte ist über
scheiße dies einmal nicht ultra strong
und ja dann einfach so oben bist du dran
jetzt muss ich gucken ja ich habe keinen
spiegel jetzt sieht man gar extra die
mir das alles ins gesicht und ja bis
dahin sage ich mal sind wir eigentlich
schon fertig mit dem ganzen scheiß weiß
ziemlich kurz da könnt ihr das auch ich
gucke weg und ich kann es
doch nicht so deutschland bin ich jetzt
auch leider schon wieder hier fertig mit
1 teil also wir gemerkt habt geht ganz
schnell drei bis fünf minuten oder so
will ich sagen ja ansonsten wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann gebt einfach meinen
daumen nach oben wenn ihr davon mehr
sehen wollt oder ab und zu mal
zwischendurch seine new dawns oder wie
es jetzt auch nennen soll ja gibt
einfach ein daumen nach oben schreibt
sind die kommentare oder so ansonsten
instagram und kobalt ist und in der
video beschreibung abonnieren nicht
vergessen wenn ihr nichts mehr verpassen
wollt und ja hier unten links geht's
weiter mit meinem letzten video das war
mit meiner freundin die sieben sekunden
challenge ist ganz cool geworden und
hier unten rechts lasst euch einfach mal
überraschen wohl dahin kommt auch ein
anderes video von mir ich würde sagen
und wir sehen uns nächste woche eine
danke für 4000 monaten hat mich echt
gefreut und haut rein